like i've never been so turned off by
fan service in my
entire life yeah oh my god it's like
it's it needs to be tasteful yeah like
as
as as a full-blown degenerate yeah it's
five force is the first time i've
actually watched like i've actually seen
full-on fan service and being like
what is this yeah this doesn't exactly
get this out of here seriously right in
front of my salad
because like you you'd have like this
really cool looking fight and like i'm
invested in this fight
right and i love like i love that stuff
i love my [ __ ] fan service but just
don't put it in front of my like fights
like dude what do they expect to be like
okay this fight scene is going to go on
for 10 minutes but we know the audience
isn't gonna pay attention
all right it's been five minutes quick
city city right now my problem with it
is that you take a break from the fight
to look at the fan service yeah right
and like i hate that because that that
disrupts the flow of the fight if the
fan service was like separate from the
fight
like in something like high school for
the dead where or something like
something like high school or dead where
like i don't know
fan service and fights are like oh come
on you didn't like the fights and [ __ ]
no i love the fights i mean there's
iconic scenes yeah yeah exactly where
the fan service is just like a part of
the fight that's [ __ ] yeah
did it ride because it's like we're
going to dedicate an entire episode
to just the raunchiest [ __ ] fan so
yeah no action whatsoever so you
know what it's going to be and then
we're going to get right into the fight
the next episode
yeah but if you like take a break from
the fight to look at the fan service
it just it's just like that eye rolling
moment yeah where even if
you [ __ ] love fan service you have no
[ __ ] problem with it
it still disrupts the [ __ ] fight so i
that's that's why i just couldn't get
into like i mean there's a lot of
reasons i can get into fly force right
right um
that was a show that was a shame right
because you know favorite production did
such a good job on the animation and
like the
art design and the character designs are
[ __ ] cool you know yeah
massive soul eater you know yeah i'm a
massive soul eater yeah
it's a massive soul eater fan right so
i'm just like hell yeah new soul leader
basically in 2020 but with a lot of fire
yeah it's like five force is one of
those shows where i've really really
wanted to [ __ ] like
but for some reason i just could not get
into it yeah i'm saying i got like four
episodes in and i was like i'm pretty
yeah three or four episodes was my limit
i think my problem with it was i felt
like a mid-2000s shonen
where shonen has like evolved past that
i feel like my hero academia and black
clover
have taken like what has worked and put
their own like twists on them
whereas fireforce feels like it still
belongs 10 years ago with better
animation
mentioning uh my hero academia it's got
a pretty notorious one no
no i don't know now i don't know okay
this is a result
of it just being the most mainstream
anime right now probably right
i imagine a lot of that has to do with
that i think so there's a lot of like
because i mean okay
the thing is with the mind here academia
fandom right is that hell yeah
is that i think it's the case of like
the same like 10 people who have the
shittest takes on twitter
that are like okay it's it's not just my
hero academia it's any like
popular shonen that
how many [ __ ] times during my heroes
uh uh like
airing period was there like tweets
people be like look at it it's
disgusting it's not even remotely close
to the manga and then they had that
they had the manga right next to it and
it's like one [ __ ] like leg
yes i love retweeting like quote
retweeting people like that like i think
there was one uh of i think it was a
screenshot from
later episode of season two or something
yeah and the the caption this this
i'm guessing it's like we both retweeted
it yeah it was like a 14 year old girl
probably captioner being like
i can't believe they would do this to my
boy yeah it was something like that and
i
literally created being like am i blind
or is it literally no
[ __ ] no because i remember seeing
that squeal and i remember thinking
wait what's the problem yeah like is
there a problem is this like party right
now are you upset that this is colored
in yeah this
this happened so many times they would
just have the the still of the animation
and a still of the manga and it was
barely any difference yes there's gonna
be some detail missing
it's a [ __ ] manga but in my opinion
it's like if you're that upset
yeah just read the [ __ ] manga like
why are you watching the anime
like i remember like logging on to
twitter whenever demon slayer was in its
peak
or when my hero academy was going to
speak i'd be like surely they can't be a
shittier taken yes they appear in my
time
and it was like everyone was everyone
was competing
they were having a tournament arc of
shitty tapes that's what it was like
when they were airing in their peaks man
i definitely do think though that the
winner of that tournament arc was that
[ __ ] person who was like uh tunjuro's
earrings
you know it's it's you know it's it's
very uh it's very bad it's got the
japanese imperial flag on it and people
just like
no that's not what it is that's not what
it is it was like a hannah
it's a hanafuda yeah it's like what are
you talking about
and i i remember i mean like i don't
usually i don't usually call people out
on twitter because i don't want to give
those people attention but sometimes i'm
just like i'm gonna give a [ __ ] if this
gets attention
this is [ __ ] hilarious it's like so
you get so many people who are like oh
dude
i found it out i found the way to like
call them out and yeah
get the woke points on twitter yeah and
they call it out everyone's like dude
shut the [ __ ] up yeah no one cares
sometimes they're like so it's so
hypocritical
because because okay i remember i
remember this one time i saw like
this tweet about like my hurricane mario
academia and the girls and like you know
don't sexualize the girls because
they're in high school and whatever
and then you go in their profile and
they're talking about shipping todoroki
i'm like what yeah
there was one girl who was like there
was like a poster that horikoshi had
drawn as like a thank you for like
season three erin and it was all of the
ua girls in like swimsuits yeah right
and some girl had retweeted being like
how dare horrible she sexualized these
14 year olds
and literally the top reply was someone
who screenshotted that person's likes
list
and it was just todoroki like yowie just
straight up like
is this you who who's this man
who's this man who's who's this yeah
it's just i don't know
what was the other one there was like a
my hero another controversy because of
course there is they find anything to
get mad
at one which one's the monotone it was
like one of the scientists
in season oh yeah that was yeah oh no
there was another one which is like uh
bakugou's birthday the same birthday as
hitler's
remember that one i don't remember you
don't remember that one
i saw that on twitter being like because
i logged onto twitter one morning and
i saw mike here academia tweet uh yeah
uh you know
trending yeah and so i was like oh god
what now so i went onto it
and it was like some some person was
like okay so the official birthdays
of uh all of the ua students came out
yeah and i just found out
that buckago's birthday is the same as
hitler's does that mean horikoshi
supports war criminals
and i'm like you can't be serious right
the worst thing about that doctor one is
like the the japanese uh like war crime
yeah yeah yeah is that i looked at it
and i was like
that's my birthday
because sea dog be a support walker i'm
like is my birthday just cancelled now
because somebody who was born on my
birthday did a bad thing
is that it was so ridiculous and i was
like this is i'm like
what do i think like what is this
because the buck ago
is hitler's birth uh hitler's birthday
tweet was so funny because all the
replies were like
that's my birthday it's like yeah they
were 365
maybe 300 yeah it's obviously gonna
overlap it's not the [ __ ] day
of the year like it's not like since
when was somebody like oh april 25th
it's hitler's birthday
another one another dumb thing was like
i think they were like uh in the anime i
think they made them like
slightly thinner compared to the manga
oh yeah people lost their [ __ ] [ __ ]
they were like i can't believe this
i can't believe they're fat shaming yeah
with these characters i'm like it's
literally two pixels
it's and i'm just there like with my
flaming hot my flaming hot cheetos just
sitting there like
it's who gives a [ __ ] i mean half the
time they don't even do that contract
i don't like get the whole redrawing art
or fixing art
trend or whatever that oh my god
happening on twitter
it is like the most toxic thing dude
artists arguing on twitter it's it's
like the most like they're just throwing
the same grenade back and forth yeah i'm
like
it's like it's like two cancer cells
fighting right it's like
oh my god you're going for the throat
joey
i mean i'm tweeting i understand with
because i remember there was one girl
who uh with uh
they did it with persona five as well
it's like how [ __ ] dare you do it
with personality because like there was
this new character in persona five royal
that came out called customy
and she's supposed to be like a
professional gymnast right yeah and
if you don't know anything about the
persona games there's like the regular
character design and then there's your
like persona character design right yeah
so the character had a gym uniform right
right like
the usual like female gym uniform yeah
and it was based around that
and there was this person who got that
and was like oh
how dare atlas sexualize this like i
think she's like
16 in the game yeah and there's like and
so like they colored in
like pretty much like the leotard part
out
to make it just look like she was
wearing a [ __ ] like skin-tight like
suit
it looked like [ __ ] and they were like i
fixed it
atlas this is this is what the
characters should look like and then
what pissed me off even more is when
a tweet like that gets popular and then
they replied to their own tweet being
like by the way guys follow me on
deviantart i'm
i'm an artist please hire me i'm like
look look artists out there
don't do that that's not how you get
hired no who are you to say what artwork
is correct
yeah like to me that's like like it's
like if we made a video and someone's
like there i corrected i dubbed over it
and made it funny yeah
okay so what it's like yeah exactly it's
because what you're doing is
you're basically just putting like a
giant middle finger at the original
artist yeah
and you don't you don't know what the
[ __ ] their intention was they just made
a piece of artwork you know especially
when it's like
you know the the cultural difference
between japan and uh
yeah yeah but like i think i think the
thing i had the biggest gripe i had with
the whole persona thing and a lot of
these like i fixed your art things is
that like there isn't anything
inherently wrong with the original art
it's just your [ __ ] prerogative that
you think it's bad like twitter's a [ __ ]
show we can all say
of course like this this recent
controversy with like the uzaki-chan
design
oh it's just the most stupid [ __ ]
thing i've seen
why is it even an argument yeah why is
it even an argument
i just i look at that [ __ ] and i'm like
how do you [ __ ] have the energy
how do you how do you do how do you wake
up every day and decide you know what
i'm gonna do today
you know argue on twitter for two hours
i'm gonna get angry about the
design of this fictional character who's
ever changed their mind because of a
[ __ ] tweet
like who in the history of humanity has
seen a tweet and been like
you know my opinions they're [ __ ]
wrong you'd be surprised